what's up everyone this is Anthony
papiano
most of you know me as pump you're
listening to off the chain
simply the best podcasting crypto let's
kick this thing off Alex Vettes key is
the founder of amber in this
conversation we discussed Bitcoin
maximalism the intolerant minority why
bitcoins community is so important how
investors should view the asset and why
the world has it priced Bitcoin properly
yet I really enjoyed this conversation
and I hope you do as well
skirt school want to know who has the
best URL crypto comm that's right
crypto comm they're a crypto platform
with one goal mother and mass adoption
that's why we're all here we're trying
to get crypto in every wallet crypto
comm is helping people do that through
buying earning lending and card payment
everything you could want at crypto
comms go help your boy out
tell them pump sent you download the app
or visit crypto comm pumps got you
always everyone to get into mining and
didn't know how don't worry your boy
pops gotcha everybody got some
electricity and Wi-Fi all you got to do
is go to coin mine comm you buy a coin
mind it's like an Xbox or a PlayStation
that helps you turn your electricity
into Bitcoin that's right you purchase
it it shows up at your doorstep you pull
it out of the box you plug it in connect
to your Wi-Fi five minutes or less
you're mining Bitcoin all you have to do
is control it from the mobile app they
provide and then you receive
over-the-air updates that add new coins
and new features on a consistent basis
kind of like how Tesla does over-the-air
updates and updates the car software
just you're updating your coin mind
consumer mining made easy that's right
go to coin mine com tell them Tom sent
you and thank me later
as many of you know crypto investors
store their digital assets on exchanges
or in cold storage for long-term
safekeeping however this strategy
doesn't help them grow their investment
holdings or build overall wealth with
the new block by interest account users
can now securely store their Bitcoin or
Ethernet block five and receive six
percent annual interest paid
flame cryptocurrency 6% is an absurdly
high rate it's the best rate in the
industry I highly suggest you go check
out block Viacom slash pomp again that's
block 5 calm slash pop to sign up and
start earning crypto today
did you follow Bitcoin and crypto you've
probably heard of eToro they're the
world's number one social trading
platform and I love it
they've got more than 10 million other
traders that love it too and guess what
they just launched the United States
eToro offers access to the world's most
popular crypto currencies including
Bitcoin etherium and others with the
smartest trading tools and the ability
to connect with the best traders around
the world there's no better place to
build your perfect portfolio if you're
new to Bitcoin and crypto you can test
the waters with a one hundred thousand
dollar virtual trading feature but if
you're more experienced you can create
custom technical charts and using Taurus
Social Feeds to inform your trading
decisions they've got transparent fees
and so you never miss out they also have
an easy-to-use application available on
iPhone Android or any web browser you
can get started today in just a few
clicks at a Toro comm again that's eToro
comm get VIP access to Bitcoin and
crypto markets today Anthony pomp lion-o
is a partner at Morgan Creek digital all
opinions expressed by pomp or his guests
on this podcast are solely their
opinions and do not reflect the opinions
of Morgan Creek digital or Morgan Creek
Capital Management you should not treat
any opinion expressed by pomp as a
specific inducement to make a particular
investment or follow a particular
strategy but only as an expression of
his opinion this podcast is for
informational purposes only
alright guys bang bang I've got Alex
here I'm super excited to do this he's
got a bunch of crazy ideas about where
the world's going so thanks so much for
taking the time to do this
thank you but thanks for having me I am
my first time in New York so um great
way to first time ever first time ever
really yeah we're gonna have to tell you
all kinds of cool things to go Disney
all right let's start with your
background you live in I'll show you now
but kind of what did you do pre Bitcoin
ozone I had a crazy background so I came
out of uni and I dropped out second year
trading the trading the markets in
in 2007 so I thought I was a genius I
started off by putting my three grand
worth of scholarship money in the
markets around early 20 2007 within
about six months I turned three grand
into sixty I thought I knew everything I
thought I was gonna be a millionaire by
the time I was 20 and then the pre GFC
tremors happened and I but but my plan
was to be a millionaire by the time I
was 20 I was a quarter of a million in
debt but I was 20 I went the opposite
way
yeah well it's funny because I think a
lot of young people there's very similar
stories right I know Chris Sacca had a
similar story to that I was lucky in
that I took a little bit of money turned
it into a lot more trading foreign
currencies in college and lost about
half of it but was still up and walked
away yeah thankfully but but I think
that that is a starting point for a lot
of people as they realize you know you
kind of learn by getting thrown into the
fire yeah well I mean that was the
catalyst so I dropped out of uni because
at that point in time I had to I had to
make fifteen hundred bucks a week just
to pay my bills before I could eat so I
literally the only thing I could the
only job I could get on short notice was
knocking on doors like selling pay
television door-to-door and I would put
four [ __ ] tuna cans so two two tuna
cans in each pocket and I would sprint
from door to door and I would only eat
if I got a sale I like that that was
love and and I dug my way out of debt
over about a year of doing that then I
set up my own sales company and then I
sort of built myself up from there I
built a renewable energy business it was
installing solar panels and [ __ ] on
people's houses because I'm in
engineering background so I can you know
in design the systems and all that sort
of stuff and and I made my first million
but time I turned like 20 to 23 and that
was sort of my my claim to fame in the
early days and I'm and then I got my
second big lesson in life which was
which was don't trust the government and
basically in the industry that I was in
they were handing out rebates and [ __ ]
to everybody right and it effectively
worked if a customer bought a 10,000
dollar system 4000 would be paid by the
customer and roughly 6000 would come
through these renewable energy
certificates which
effectively the the government funding
element the government towards right at
the end of the of the scheme they sort
of three weeks out said I look if we're
ending the rebate in three weeks if you
don't sign up in three weeks you miss
out and everyone went [ __ ]
gangbusters like we signed up maybe five
or ten million dollars worth of systems
in like a couple weeks like we thought
we [ __ ] nailed it and were like
alright sweet you know we'll have to
transition the mark is gonna be slower
but we've got enough systems to last us
for a while and anyway we went and
installed all those systems and in that
10k chunk there's probably about ten
fifteen percent margin left in that when
it came time to pay out the the six
grand the government component we
everyone got fifty cents on the dollar
why well they ran out of money basically
that that's the easiest way to put it so
so we went from having profit on every
job to every job being a [ __ ] loss
and the more jobs you did the more you
lost so that was my second big thing so
I lost a shitload of money there I you
know I then went on a sabbatical
the thing that saved me during that
period was after the market crash in you
know 28 2008 I really went down that the
the gold silver and you know monetary
sort of stuff and I I had bought like
some golden silver because I was
convinced the world was coming to an end
I was half a [ __ ] prepper whilst I
was still doing the solar stuffs so it
was just it was a really interesting
period so I got [ __ ] with that and
then I ended up going on this sabbatical
and know many people know this but I
actually became a vegan for like for
like a year and a half I went like
that's not allowed in Bitcoin but do you
think I was curious enough to try it and
I actually came out of that knowing that
that is the [ __ ] dumbest way to eat
like it is okay absolutely categorically
the would you wait when did you do this
for how long this was in 2012 okay her
to about 2013 so mostly weird yes oh
well call it I started being vegan just
before 2012 and I finished like sort of
coming into 2014 it was about a year and
a half that I was okay so I was
vegetarian for five months or so I mean
20
despite 2016-2017 May 2017 yep um I
actually never felt better in not eating
meat but it was unsustainable because I
lost so much weight and I just couldn't
I just I couldn't make it this is where
plant-based works plant-based works if
you want to cleanse or if you want to
clear out some [ __ ] okay but it is very
very bad for hormones for hormone
regulation for muscle and for nutrient
density so what happens is so I actually
of course Matt was giving me [ __ ] last
night because when I went vegan I wanted
to write a book about it and show that
you could actually build muscle and do
all this sort of [ __ ] being a vegan and
for the first six months I felt [ __ ]
incredible my energy was better my skin
was better my like all this sores that
so I thought I found the holy [ __ ]
Grail so I started doing this thing but
over time I plateaued and then after I
plateaued all my strength started come
down my hormones started to get all
[ __ ] up my you know might [ __ ] start
losing hair I was getting flabby all
this sort of [ __ ] started happening over
time because what happens is your
hormones miss regulate so when I started
eating meat again so I was convinced by
this dude because I was living in Bondi
at the time which is sort of like health
maker in Australia and he sort of snuck
some lamb into one of my vegan meals the
[ __ ]
and I went from there to eating some
eggs and then I don't know if I can say
this on the podcast but I'm gonna [ __ ]
say it anyway did when I started eating
some some meat again I had a I had a
[ __ ] boner for three weeks but I
swear to God like my home like I went
back to from benching like I used to
bench 220 pounds and I went down to like
120 pounds and then I went back to 220
pounds within 3 weeks like I wanted to
have sex with every girl that I saw want
to beat the [ __ ] out of every guy that I
saw like I I was like [ __ ] this is what
I was missing out on yup and so that's
where meat is really important nutrient
density its hormones and it's um it's
it's [ __ ] strength it's groundedness
yep which you don't get in BV so anyway
I'm coming back to the journey so I was
a minor detour
I'd heard about Bitcoin at the stage but
I dismissed it because I was too
involved in thinking that the world
coming to an end and I was stockpiling
gold silver I was you know [ __ ]
buying solar panels and batteries and
prepping you know for the end of times
and anyway after that whole sabbatical I
I came back to Australia and um and I
spent some time in singularity
University okay now in nsv in about 2014
and I was like holy [ __ ] Tech is the way
came back I built some payroll
automation software exited that and then
built up this um this recruitment
automation software I got Steve Jobs out
of my own business I I disagreed with
the way the board wanted to run the
company and all this sort of [ __ ] so I
moved on
and that was sort of my foray into
Bitcoin so twenty twenty sixteen was
when I really like went down the rabbit
hole and and what was the initial
interest it right so you've heard about
it before you dismissed it yeah we were
talking before we started I had a very
similar journey I think but was the
thing that really threw you down the
rabbit hole you're like the hey I gotta
check this out see this is real if I
boil it down to like that the the hook
was the price I saw the price I was like
holy [ __ ] I was like this is $600 now
like the last time I'd heard about it it
was like 150 or whatever it was and I
was like [ __ ] me like I've just busted
my ass working and doing all this sort
of stuff and I could have just put some
money into this thing and gone to the
Bahamas so that was my initial hook and
then I I need to give credit where
credit's due like I don't agree with
many of Andreas Antonopoulos stuff these
days where he talks about [ __ ]
everything's gonna have a toke and
everything's gonna have a coin but he's
initial talks because because I've got a
background also in you know psychology I
studied anthropology history and all the
sort of stuff and the way he presented
Bitcoin just really really lined up with
my background and the way I think about
things and yeah man I like he's his
works his talks I went down that rabbit
hole and you know obviously sayfudine
stuff I'll give some credit to two-tone
vase as well like he was he was like one
of those intolerant bitcoiners that you
know wouldn't you know it was Bitcoin or
you know [ __ ] coin basically alright
show this shirt he brought he brought a
shirt to to really get people all upset
it says Bitcoin not [ __ ] coin amber dot
app so we'll get that out there because
he wanted to to make sure that everyone
knew where this conversation was going
early on exactly
all right so let's talk a little bit
about Bitcoin maximalism and those that
are listening at home we've got the the
live stream going on Twitter right now
so there may be some people who jump it
with some questions that we take as well
but Bitcoin maximalism is generally
associated with a negative connotation
it's toxic its tribalism it's all these
things just talk a little bit about how
you think about Bitcoin maximalism and
why you actually think it's important
versus it being something negative yeah
well I've got a friend of mine and shout
out to Rory highside here he coined the
term which I loved which is Bitcoin
supremacy and that is like literally
it's beyond maximalism it is we don't
even recognize anything other than
Bitcoin and the reason I think this is
important is um we have a chance at
creating a monetary network and a new
money that is robust that is secure that
is that is available that is fixed I
think the fixed element is so
fundamentally important because if you
look at what money is supposed to
represent money's supposed to represent
your work or your input into a society
and work input and time are all fixed
constants in the universe and what we've
got in today's society and in everything
that we've had in the past is we've not
been able to map work or time or effort
put into society directly to money when
money is supposed to be the measurement
of those things we've now created
something that literally represents that
and by definition you know if we're
talking about digital scarcity and
fixed-fixed digital unit we've got that
now and all of our energy all of our
time all of our efforts should be going
into making that stronger and bringing
that to more people so for me I see this
as a a multi-decade
multi-generational shift that you know
people are going to move towards the UM
the strongest form of money because of
their own self-interest when you do work
like people fundamentally value their
time
value their work they value what they're
doing they're not going to want to
long-term represent that time or value
or work in any unit other than the one
with the greatest guarantee of I guess
supply security uncensor ability on
confiscate ability the things that
Bitcoin represents and that's all the
[ __ ] that Bitcoin has optimized for
outside of what every other [ __ ] coin or
crypto or anything like that has gone
and tried to optimize for whether it's
fast payments whether it's you know the
the stupid world computer or whatever
other [ __ ] idea that people have
taken and tried to use the Bitcoin
recipe for so coming then back to
Bitcoin maximalist is the intolerant
minority that they represent so the the
cohort of people that they represent um
I was talking I was talking to Matt
Odell about this last night and we kind
of use the the example of the be caches
I don't know about you but every BK sure
that I've ever spoken to a lot of the
things a lot of the ways that they view
a Bitcoin are correct until you sort of
get to like the scaling debate and you
know how you know that they miss some
misinterpret what the definition of cash
is and the dangers around really
centralizing nodes and all that but um
the thing that you'll note about be
caches is most of them if not all of
them hedge themselves by holding some
Bitcoin whereas you look at the
bitcoiners they dumped all of their
[ __ ] Bitcoin cash they dumped any
other fork so that intolerant ability to
stick with what you believe in is really
unique to the Bitcoin group and the
Bitcoin max is because we come from a
core of people who will not compromise
who will not you know adjust our values
just because it sounds nice or because
you know sir you know we're gonna be
hurting somebody's [ __ ] feelings or
any of that sort of stuff
it is literally Bitcoin bitcoins
consensus rules and that's it that no we
will not waver from that and the reason
that's important is because this is a
movement this is literally
this is the revolution of our time we're
separating money from state the last
revolution that happened of this
magnitude was the separation of church
and state and that was you know the
emergence of science and the Renaissance
you know four or five hundred years ago
like that that is a big [ __ ] deal
yeah one of the things that I definitely
think people misunderstand right so I
talk all the time I say look what is a
belief system and most people will agree
with that to some degree and if money is
a belief system then money ends up
looking very similar to religion right
if you look at the US dollar literally
you know in god we trust' write the full
faith and backing of the government all
these things are inherent to money and
they happen for a very long time it
would make sense that people have a very
zealous or religious like view towards
the next money right which is Bitcoin
and in that situation I think what
you're basically describing is a very in
some people's eyes fanatical approach to
those ethos to that belief and saying
look this is what we believe and if we
believe this we're not willing to
compromise we're not willing to waver
from this that this is what we believe
in therefore we are here to defend it
both kind of in the way that we talk
about it but also to attack the ideas
that are they go against quick well it
feels fanatical to people because people
don't appreciate how important money is
in society like you know we've been sort
of taught over time that our money is
the root of all evil you know money's
just for these [ __ ] were selfish
and all this sort of stuff right but if
you take a moment to think about it if
money is the tool that literally holds
fabric that the fabric of society
together you cannot have society without
money you remove that element society
falls apart because if if we define
society as a collection of inputs from a
collective of participants the only way
these participants can collaborate and
build a society is by performing some
sort of function or work within a
society and
that function or work needs to be
measured through some form of unit and
that unit is money so see so you cannot
have it so you cannot have society with
that money so if we if any of the people
listening to this or anyone hearing this
values anything that you have in life
it's because money actually exists
that's it now the reason why people are
so fervent about you know something like
Bitcoin is because now for the first
time in history we've got a way to
represent money that is that is
uncompromising that is so [ __ ]
important because when you can fix that
layer you can really start to build a
world that is incentivized appropriately
ie
in today's day and age always use this
example when I try and explain to people
why bitcoins really important in today's
day and age if you're a government or if
you're a central bank you basically have
you can play the game where it's I flip
a coin heads I win tails you lose
in other words they can make a bet and
if they make a good bet they um they
make money if they make a bad bet they
make money you and I in the real world
we go out there and you you make a good
bet you make a good decision by and
large you know not not counting for
randomness you get a good outcome you do
is [ __ ] something stupid you get a
bad outcome right that that is the
corrective mechanism of all of life of
all the physics of all of science right
only in the monetary system do you have
a situation where one the vast majority
of society has to abide by those rules
do something smart get a good result do
something dumb get a bad result whereas
a small subset of society can do
whatever the [ __ ] they want and they get
a good result
irrespective and then that starts to
create distortions in society so when
you can separate money and state which
is gonna be the I guarantee that is the
battlefront of today's day and age when
you can separate those two and make
money a fixed constant that is
uncompromised will uncomfortable and
unable to be censored by anybody you
have a society where the only way to
earn more of that resource is by
performing all work adding more value or
doing more officers
society that's it you don't have any
other [ __ ] way so therefore the only
way for you to UM to excel in life or to
move forward is by adding value society
or the alternative is you [ __ ] steal
but you know the beauty of a society
like that is you can build you know
property rights into it such that you
know the deterrent to steal is large
enough such that people's incentive is
to add value and to produce because that
is how [ __ ] that that is how society
should function so well and I think part
of this right is if you think out at
every single country they all have
different monetary policies they all
have different governments and one of
the things that I've always found
interesting slash confusing is if you
and I are trading and we're going to
denominated trade or settled that trade
a lot of times I don't know what you're
doing with your currency if you're a
different country you don't know what
I'm doing with mine and therefore we're
trying to make a one-time trade where
it's basically a spot price right okay
here's her where the Carty is let's make
this transaction but if you get into
more longer-term
type relationships where I could easily
manipulate my currency you can easily
manipulate yours you end up getting this
financial engineering key right it's not
true quick sent its quick sent literally
we're living in a time of monetary quick
sent when nobody knows what the [ __ ] is
going on no and you know it's not only
that we don't know what the other person
is doing we actually have no idea what
we're doing so there's a um there's a
branch of complexity theory called
systems thinking and I and I recommend
everybody look into some system thinking
and start to understand how this happens
but I'm effectively you've got a system
which is complex and you have a set of
inputs and outputs and when you perform
when you add some sort of input into a
system it's very very difficult almost
nigh on impossible in a complex system
to understand what the ramifications are
going to be on this side and that's what
we've got with markets today and that's
what we've got with central banking and
that in the current system is we're
literally playing games which we don't
understand we're like oh what if we are
press this button here what the [ __ ] is
that going to do ah if I can just did
this this this which we wanted it to do
but here's another 10,000 side effects
that we
expecting ah now how do we fix those
side effects oh well let's push this
button here and then that fixes a couple
of those and then creates another 5,000
side effects so we've got this game of
like cat and mouse where we're
continually adding fragility to the
system to the point where that's the
shits gonna blow up in our face yeah
well it's I think what you're really
talking about here is anytime that the
system goes to structurally correct
right so there are just like in any
system where there's a market markets
can get overheated or under heated right
so no no more functions yeah what we
have seen is when those markets go to
correct central Baker's step in
artificially to try to correct it now
there is an argument to be made a moral
ethical and more a societal argument
that says any sort of downturn in an
economy can be incredibly painful and
can hurt a lot of people right so
there's there's that piece of it the
other side of that argument is but it is
normal and it is better for the
long-term sustainability of the system
correct so let's talk about why it's
normal actually I was I was a denier
being being um in Palm Springs the other
day for for crypto Springs and I was
talking to the a B&B host there and he
was sitting there telling y'all you know
blah blah blah you know recessions are
bad and you know we need to avoid
recession all their stuff and I was like
what why why are recessions bad let's
take the idea of a downturn and the idea
of a break and apply it to a situation
outside of markets because because this
is this constant chase to avoid
recession to avoid pain I think is one
of the root problems with society today
we are all chasing the next [ __ ] high
the next hit the next bit of you know
dopamine released happiness because
we're so afraid to experience a bit of
lull a bit of pain or a bit of downtime
so if you let's say you go to the gym
right you go and train you go and lift
[ __ ] weights what do you do between
sets you rest you rest you stop for a
minute so the whole nature functions in
this way you one must when you when you
exert when you move up you must take a
moment to rest you have to take a moment
you there needs to be intervals you
cannot move in
a single direction forever that is not
how nature functions that is not how the
universe functions nothing nothing else
in the world functions like that and
we've become addicted to this idea that
everything must move up and in a in a in
a single direction as if downturns or
recessions about recessions downturns
breaks you know opportunities to reflect
one of the most important functions of
any system because they allow you to
take a moment to breathe a bit realize
there's a return back to kind of the
average right if you will and so the
average is there for a reason but what I
think becomes more interesting is when
the central bankers step in and they try
to manipulate the economy in a way to
prevent those downturns right so they
drop interest rates they print money all
the things that we know that they do
what they're really doing is not fixing
the structural issues who are allowing
the market to find a point of
equilibrium what they're doing is
they're kicking the can down the road
they're kicking the can down the road
and they could they're increasing the
the deviation from the mean so when the
time comes to rebalance it's going to be
all the more painful so what we're doing
is we're sacrificing this comes back to
the UM to the how what do you call it
the UH the incentive mechanism that I
was talking about earlier in today's day
and age the world we live in today
the incentive is to value today more
than tomorrow mm-hmm whereas the
incentive in a Bitcoin ecosystem is to
value tomorrow greater than today's to
have a lower time preference it doesn't
mean that's going around now so by
valuing today more than tomorrow we
continually kick the can down the road
and we're creating a situation where our
children and our children's children are
gonna have to bear a debt or they're
gonna have some sort of [ __ ] blow up in
their face or because we were too stupid
too weak and too impatient to want to
you know go in and actually fix the
stuff that we've messed up yeah well you
know it's the whole idea of it's like
drinking right exactly it's dreams or
drugs when we drink the first beer it
tastes really good you know like man I
really miss having a beer I want to have
a second one you have a second a third
or fourth or fifth and they say you know
you're drunk and
you're drunk it's amazing you feel like
you're on top of the world right no one
can stop you exception where you feel
the negative effect is the next morning
when you're hungover did I'm gonna say
it's even more like drugs actually you
take a drug you feel high you get you
come down and you want to get that high
feeling again so you take another drug
you do have another drug and then all of
a sudden you become addicted and the
only way to quit is by [ __ ] stopping
yeah that's it it's the only way you
gonna get better because you could
continually get higher forever you're
just gonna kill yourself at some point
and that is exactly what like we are
living in an economy at a time where
everyone's high literally we're all high
on dopamine
yeah well the markets are higher Real
Estate's higher everything's high
everyone's on drugs like we're so
extended that you know we need a
rebalancing that just the problem is
gonna be and unfortunately for most
people that rebalancing is gonna be
really really painful because we've
moved so far away from the mean then
it's gonna be hard to UM to manage that
reversion in a sensible manner for sure
let's go deeper on this idea of the
intolerant minority we're talking about
describe what that is and what the
importance is soso talib talks about
that and I'm pretty sure that's in skin
in the game no I mean his book and he
talks about how intolerant minorities
are the drivers are the catalysts for
movements and for broad-based changes
because they will not compromise on any
values or anything that they believe in
so he uses an example of like kosher
food for example it is much easier for a
large scale food manufacturer to make
all of their food kosher because you and
I we may or may not be Jewish whatever
the case is we will eat kosher food but
people who are Jewish will not eat
kosher food so instead of making two
lines what they do is they just make all
the food kosher because then they can
cater for everyone and that is as a
result of catering for the intolerant
minority the same thing is going to
happen here is we've got this intolerant
minority of bitcoiners who are true to
the sanctity of what bitcoin represents
which is an uncensored uncut Abul
uninflated will form of money so and and
the reason we're so intolerant about
that is because we've spent the time
to sit down and understand what money
represents most people haven't done that
most people just I recently tweeted I
said on a percentage basis of
percentages there are more people on
crypto twitter who understand what money
is then people on Wall Street yeah and
I'm gonna say well I'm gonna new ants
that and I'm gonna say Bitcoin Twitter
okay yeah good cuz literally I don't
think many people on cryptids would are
actually understand what money is most
people in crypto Twitter I think take a
technologists viewpoint of what this
thing is
I believe bitcoin is a monetary
phenomenon not a technological
phenomenon although they're inextricably
linked
the monetary phenomenon here is where
the game is at okay so this is an idea
that I actually haven't talked about
publicly yet but behind closed doors
I've been talking more and more about
with companies that we're invested in or
other investors which is a lot of what
we're seeing here the winners are not
going to be technological innovations
right it is actually going to be what I
call another network effect but a
liquidity effect right and that a
liquidity effect essentially is you know
take Bitcoin you could have somebody
else recreate every single technical
component of Bitcoin and launch it
tomorrow the problem is that they don't
have the quote-unquote liquidity in the
supply and demand of people who want to
hold it or people who want to use it and
therefore that liquidity effect is
actually what the defining feature is
not the technical effect now exactly so
okay so I'm gonna I'm gonna nuance that
argument a little bit because I talked
about that when I explained why bitcoin
is the UM is the only game in town in
this space is um step one that the first
thing that another network cannot
replicate on um with respect to UM to
Bitcoin is you cannot replicate the the
life that the period of time that how
Bitcoin was launched the initial holders
the libertarian movement the
disappearance of Satoshi and everything
that happened at that point in time
bitcoins initial dismissal by the world
people thinking that our mining is a
[ __ ] joke and all this little stuff
Bitcoin is successful now because it was
initially dismissed and that period of
time you cannot replicate there is no it
is actually physically impossible to go
back in time and to produce the same run
so so that's the first piece what and it
only grew in the shadows
exactly nobody can go and replicate that
because none of us like this isn't
[ __ ] Back to the Future right we
can't go and jump in you know we're not
Marty McFly and we can't go and
replicate that future again with
something else so that's the first piece
but Marty bent might be Marty McFly
maybe maybe maybe if anyone can do it
it's him but that that's the first piece
so now once we've ticked that box
because of those elements the Bitcoin
now has the most liquidity and if we
look at what money is money is supposed
to be the most liquid good on the face
of the planet
it is the good against which we price
everything so you've got this what's
called a convergent network effect which
is the more liquid a money is the more
liquidity it starts to draw in because
people want to have or hold the money
that is the most liquid now the more so
basically liquidity attracts more
liquidity and and now that bitcoin is
already the the size and the degree to
which it is for every year that Bitcoin
grows any other [ __ ] coin even if they
somehow manage to solve or create their
own initial complex method of growth
like you know their [ __ ] founder
disappeared or whatever it would take
them ten years to catch up for every
year that Bitcoin grows so it's too late
the train has already taken off those
kind of network effects you cannot catch
so you've got this convergent network
effect happen you've got this liquidity
reinforcing happening and you've got
this unique what Gigi who am who wrote
the 21 lessons he calls it this
immaculate conception is no you it
happened once we ain't gonna [ __ ]
repeat that furthermore you've got
digital scarcity which is a one-time
event that's another thing and then
you've got these this optimization for
the objective attributes that bitcoin
has which is it optimizes for uncensor
ability for uninflated bility for unn
confiscate ability those objective
attributes help reinforce the belief
system around bitcoin being a superior
money because we've got objective
attributes of bitcoin that we can all
agree to much like why gold became a
better form of money than iron or copper
it was an inert metal it was scarce it
was harder to produce it was more
recognizable all of these objective
actor
or elements about it so all of these
reasons together mean that bitcoin is in
a position where it cannot be beaten
maybe maybe maybe maybe six or seven
years ago you know maybe even five years
ago it's too late the ship sale well so
and part of this too is not only the
Bitcoin was able to grow in the shadows
but one of the things that I think about
a lot is the lack of selfishness that
Satoshi Nakamoto had right you know that
there are this I'm not aware of a single
token cryptocurrency exception it has
been created yet where we don't know who
created correct and it never will be and
it never will be
that's the thing because that this was
done now anyone who does produce it it's
in order to cover your tracks the way
that Satoshi did we don't live in a
world like that anymore that was it was
a one-time event it happened then
because it was able to happen that this
ain't gonna [ __ ] happen again you
know it happened right in the UM in the
depths of the GFC that [ __ ] ain't gonna
[ __ ] happening in the timing that the
period that the style the way it was
done that was an immaculate conception
and it's all over
game set match um the other thing I'm
also gonna mention that just quickly
about what you just mentioned on
satoshis like benevolence like the fact
that he came in he created this and I'm
any left eye when you look at the
Bitcoin community and you look at the
you know the so-called toxic maximalists
when you look at what they're doing in
their intolerance to [ __ ] coronary their
intolerance to this whole [ __ ]
blockchain crap that's going around
their intolerance to anything other than
Bitcoin they're actually they're an
extension of the service that Satoshi
provided which is when I go out and tell
people about Bitcoin I'm doing it from a
place of yes I want to pump my own bags
in you know in one sense you know so
there is that selfishness you know
around it but really what I'm doing is
I'm actually doing a service to this
person and helping them avoid losing
their [ __ ] hard-earned time money and
effort on investing in a [ __ ] coin or
going down the path of blockchain
are--or [ __ ] coronary or all of that
sort of stuff that doesn't matter so I'm
actually doing them service so if you
look at the the the Bitcoin community
especially there's hard
Maximus who get a lot of [ __ ] those guys
are the missionaries they are the people
that are doing more service to people
coming into the space then any other
Muppet that is out there trying to
promote their own [ __ ] coin or create
their own [ __ ] coin or sit there and you
know poopoo and Bitcoin because they
want to sell their own you know agenda
or their own thing yeah like these
maximalists are literally doing the
greatest service to the community and
they're doing it whilst copying all of
this heat calling them toxic calling
them [ __ ] calling them [ __ ]
come in and we sort of we take that in
will I call us what you want we will not
[ __ ] move from this line and we will
maintain the standard and at some point
you will come around and thank us for
not deviating but I think that's no good
if you look pretty early on at most
large successful companies
there was a especially in technology
there was a founder or a founding team
that had a very principal or missionary
based they had a very low level of
social skills a lot of times which led
to their [ __ ] they don't get it that
you know all this kind of negative
feedback but they stayed very very very
focused on what they were trying to
build and why was important and that
focus and that lack of deviation from
that mission ended up leading to
significant impact outcomes on the world
right I think that money is not only no
different it's probably just all of that
stuff on a much greater scale correct
that's so it's so much broader like I
was trying to explain to someone the
other week that um that the market that
money represents is immeasurable it is
the biggest market this is the biggest
opportunity and the biggest market
aren't kids like Apple all of the tech
companies all the [ __ ] pales in
comparison because they're all measured
through a monetary unit anyway like
system money absorbs and encompasses all
of it it's so much [ __ ] bigger like
to to your point there that you just
touched on I always ask this question to
people would you prefer an honest
[ __ ] or a polite liar it's a great
point it is it's one of the most
employed and most people believe it or
not they'll say
an honest [ __ ] but in real life
they'll hang out with Peleus yep I'm
sure and and that is a [ __ ] shame
because that's again another function of
the world we live in which is everyone
is too too afraid to be called out too
afraid to be butthurt too afraid to be
you know to be confronted with reality
so we go and you know placate ourselves
and placate those around us with what
may not be outright lies but you know we
we meander around points we soften
things you know we do all this sort of
stuff just to see and that's not true
just in crypto right that's true it's
whole society and that's why people in
the Bitcoin space come off so you know
quote-unquote toxic or like Arsenal's
because guess what we're honest [ __ ]
yeah what's it goes back to the whole
idea of like nomenclature in words
really matter I usually talk about that
in a sense of you know when we go to war
we said we're gonna go fight insurgents
for not by humans right really sanctions
somebody we don't talk about we're gonna
censor them we talk about we're gonna
sanction them same thing here is you can
say hey that person is toxic or you can
say that person refuses to say anything
other than the truth yes right yes those
two things are not necessarily
incompatible with each other and also if
you were to say that person refuses to
say anything but the truth all of a
sudden now you might be much more
attracted to listening to what that
person has to say
versus the negatively connotated that
person's toxic or a max 100% do you know
what I love about the Bitcoin community
is that we take those memes anyway so we
take an insult you know initially
maximalism was an insult from Vitalik
right we took it and we've turned it
into a powerful meme that we can you
know that's a lightning rod through
which you know bitcoiners now congregate
around then the next one oh you're a
toxic [ __ ] bitcoin now we've taken
that and we wear that [ __ ] with pride
like you've seen Samson's caps like
we'll walk around with that [ __ ] and we
hold that with pride because we're not
afraid of [ __ ] words like it's the
sticks and stones may break my bones but
you know names will never hurt me it's
like we don't give a [ __ ] about that
because we you know that that's not you
can call us whatever names you want
we're here to do a service for the world
and at some point in time you'll come
around and you'll thank us not only for
being intolerant but you'll thank us for
having the courage to
intolerant despite the [ __ ] insults
and despite all that stuff so one of the
questions I get quite often and I've got
an opinion but I want to hear yours
first before I reveal mine is if Bitcoin
fails can anything else succeed I mean
the if Bitcoin fails what succeeds is
basically 1984 George Orwell [ __ ]
Social Credit System you know explain it
is like if we look at the way like let's
go back to the cypherpunks you know that
the soft punks 20 30 40 years ago
whatever it was now I think it's you
know Jesus it's 30 something years ago
right in the manifesto like you know and
I'm gonna really crudely paraphrase here
that they were saying the world is
becoming electronic its digitizing and
the more it does the more the sanctity
of privacy is going to be diminished you
know the ability to communicate
privately with someone across you know
electronic networks or digital networks
is going to be it's going to be impacted
because authorities or central parties
are going to be running this stuff so we
need to create open encryption standards
such that communication can remain
private furthermore we need to create a
form of money that can remain private
and uncensor of all such that people can
live in a free society when society
starts to digitize and become electronic
that was the foresight so bitcoins not
and a 10 year old idea Bitcoin is a 20
30 year old idea it's always been around
so what they set out to do first and we
managed to crack the the communicate
like private communication first
obviously that was a much easier problem
to crack the second problem was much
harder and obviously Satoshi cracked it
in 2008 which is why it's so profound
and without that the world that we're
gonna live in is literally the world
that I'm that you know is described so
well in the movies like V for Vendetta
or the matrix or you know George
Orwell's book 1984 which is that let's
look at it this way
if money is the resource through which
we measure Society and the resource
through which you know your value and
effort and energy is measured and the
resource through which you can trade and
participate and actually you know buy
other goods if you live in a society
where that is concentrated or able to be
centralized
and managed by someone you even if that
someone is a good actor and you know
once the best for their people you know
something evil and dictator or whatever
you you have a high degree of risk or
you're in a very precarious situation
where let's say you like the wrong
[ __ ] thing you say the wrong thing
your ability to participate in an
economy is just simply switched off you
can't get on a bus you can't buy food
you can't do [ __ ] [ __ ] well this is
war seen with the Chinese credit system
right which is essentially imagine if
you want to take the Express bus but
you're not allowed to because you came
to work late today so they're gonna rush
you now on the way home you have to
quote-unquote suffer rather get punished
yeah you can't take the Express bus they
have to take something else that sounds
like a really far off crazy kind of like
sci-fi based world but I don't think
we're that far off dude it is happening
right now it is happening right now
there was like without Bitcoin that is
the world we get and this is what I tell
people is like whilst yeah you know what
we're all about you know making money
with Bitcoin in the up side and all of
that sort of stuff what I'm more about
more touching this later is the the idea
of collecting Bitcoin now because it is
the only free money that exists in this
world it is the only opt-out from a
world that is studies converging towards
concentration and concentration in a
manner that creates mal incentives for
those people who are running it hmm to
do [ __ ] that may not be in the interest
of freedom alright so before we get to
that though one one of the things I want
to talk about is this idea that we are
now seeing a showdown between
corporations and countries over that
control yep right so we see deep
platforming yep we see censorship
mmm-hmm from many corporations which was
previously a nefarious activity reserved
for governments yep right now
corporations have gotten that ability
because they own the platforms on which
we're speaking if governments and
corporations are able to do this stuff
they end up competing over almost who
can be works right who has more power
who is more control and this is where
you see some of the stuff I think
States in the technology world of the
who has anti-competitive behaviour
somebody have a monopoly if I can but
what monopoly does Facebook have what
hasn't a monopoly on attention yes right
it has a monopoly on a platform for
speech yep a lot of people who aren't
comfortable with that right and so I
think that when you look at that what
we're talking about with Bitcoin is it's
a way to bring back the monopoly on time
on money on value all this stuff but
we're doing it with from day one it was
designed in a way where it does not
matter later life anyone wants me to
Farias they cannot get control assistant
skirts girl want to know who has the
best URL crypto calm that's right
crypto calm they're crypto platform with
one goal mother mass adoption that's why
we're all here
we're trying to get crypto in every
wallet crypto calm is helping people do
that through buying earning lending and
card payment everything you could want
at crypto calm go help your boy out
tell them pomp sense you download the
app or visit crypto comm pumps got you
always everyone to get into mining and
didn't know how don't worry your boy
pops gotcha everybody got some
electricity and Wi-Fi all you got to do
is go to coin mine comm you buy a coin
mine it's like an Xbox or a Playstation
that helps you turn your electricity
into Bitcoin that's right you purchase
it it shows up at your doorstep you pull
it out of the box you plug it in connect
to your Wi-Fi five minutes or less
you're mining Bitcoin all you have to do
is control it from the mobile app they
provide and then you receive
over-the-air updates that add new coins
and new features on a consistent basis
kind of like how Tesla does over-the-air
updates and updates the car software
just you're updating your coin mind
consumer mining made easy that's right
go to coin mine calm tell them pomp
Sencha and thank me later
one more word from our sponsor block buy
their new interest account allows you to
securely deposit your Bitcoin or ether
at block five and receive 6% annual
interest paid monthly and cryptocurrency
this rate actually compound so you
receive a 6.2 percent APY which is very
attractive given the alternatives
so you can actually take your Bitcoin
you can deposit it with block Phi and
get paid an interest rate of 6% in
return go check out block 5 comm / pump
again block 5 comm / pump to sign up and
start earning interest on your crypto
today so you touching a really
interesting point if we are seeing the
corporations and the governments the
world censoring and doing all of this
stuff with things that just you know
like social media for [ __ ] sake which
is nowhere near as important as money
what do you think they're gonna do if
they've got the same type of control of
money well they're and they're doing it
now right so I I continue to say this
and again it's sometimes it's unpopular
so I always caveat it with there are
reasons and very strong arguments to be
made for sanctions right I am not in any
way saying that I am against sanctioning
but if we were to go out and tell the
United States people that we are going
to cut off millions of people in another
country the citizens from the global
financial system I think there's a lot
of people who be asking questions why
are we doing that how is that happening
what is there other alternative options
you know how are those people gonna get
food money how are they gonna make a
living survive all these different
things but what we do is when we
sanction other countries we are simply
censoring them and what we're doing
we're trying to apply pressure we're
engaging in economic combat right or war
in order to force or heavily incentivize
the leadership of those countries to do
things we want them to do yet yeah so
again it's a completely rational
position to take for the world's
superpower and controller of the reserve
currency because it's the world we live
in today yes
but the problem becomes the impact that
it has on below the leadership of that
country can be devastating absolutely
absolutely and again like you know I'm
not gonna sit here and talk about you
know what's right or wrong from you know
people's freedom and all those sort of
[ __ ] like that that that's that that is
what it is in the world we live in today
like the u.s. is the reserve currency
and you know it is doing things game
theoretically that makes sense for it to
remain some sort of reserve currency but
the world that we're building on Bitcoin
is
I believe you know bitcoins so profound
is that where we're reinventing a new
world with its own economic system that
doesn't have to that doesn't need
anything from the old world so we can
just build from scratch our own [ __ ]
way irrespective of what the rest of the
world is doing and over time people are
going to notice that what we're doing
here functions better yeah it looks
nicer
it feels nicer it's more equitable it's
free the incentive systems the
incentives are aligned in a much more
productive way like all this so people
will come over this goes to my whole
theory that and Parker Lewis I think
from munching capital said it perfectly
it's like gradually then suddenly right
and I think a lot about this idea of we
first started to develop a thesis around
why is Bitcoin important to the world
you know this is actually going to last
is the sustainable stuff it was people
will trust software or algorithms right
especially in a decentralized world to
store their wealth right that was kind
of step one what we didn't realize but
now I've come to the conclusion of is
it's not that you go from 100% in the
legacy financial system to 100% in this
Bitcoin and cryptocurrency system no
what you do is you say I'm a hundred
percent to one legacy system to new
system but you know what I actually
think this new things interesting
they put 1% 5% 10% right some small
number and then you learn and you spend
time and you see how it works and you
kind of become more familiar with it
more educated more and becomes less
scary to you then you go from 1 5 10% to
25% 50% to eventually over a long period
of time it will be 100 percent right and
so what you actually need is you need
people first to make the binary I'm open
to putting some percentage and then once
they start with some percentage even if
it's one person then it goes to okay now
how do we get from 1% to full more kind
of wallet share if you want or wealth
share okay so that reminds me of um and
I can't remember if it was Hayek or one
of the other Austrian economists see he
was like you know we need to create a
money that is not earned by government
that in some sneaky sort of way becomes
the money that we all use and if you
look at Bitcoin this is why I love big
design and I feel like it's just so like
perfect is um bitcoins and monetary
beasts and when someone says you know
how is it going to become you know the
reserve currency will how its because
through through tapping into one of our
strongest drives I agreed or the desire
for a better future it is going to
incentivize everybody around the world
in some way shape or form to participate
or get some exposure to Bitcoin today
and as they do that like I've got a
saying which I say I came for the money
and I stayed for the money right which
is I came for the money cuz I was well I
wanted [ __ ] gains but I've stayed for
the money because now I realized this is
the money mm-hmm and what's gonna
everyone's gonna go through that journey
simple as that they're gonna come in for
the money they're gonna come in for the
incentive of a future return and as they
stay in it and as they go from 1% to 2%
to 5% exposure they're literally gonna
get sucked into a monetary system that
is superior to the system that they're
currently in yeah and and it's gonna do
that all through initially tapping into
greed and then over time
delivering on the promise which is
survival like if you've read Richard
Dawkins Selfish Gene right it's we are
optimized for survival we're a living
[ __ ] organism and again we increase
our chances of survival through having
our wealth stored in a more functional
form so it is this this is why you just
can't [ __ ] beat it like none of the
government's are gonna come close to so
I want to talk about another idea that
you have which is this idea of
collecting Bitcoin yep right I know that
there's a saying or a mean that's really
gone out there which is stacks at you
right and maybe describe a little bit
about what you mean by collect Bitcoin
and kind of how that compares to the
stacks yes
so mera dil and the guys they came up
with stacking stats and it was just it
is the best [ __ ] mean it sounds cool
and it's a way that we can really brand
Bitcoin is something cool right what
I've what I found though is I've started
doing some talks around universities and
everything are straight and when I say
stacking stats sort of people like look
at me like [ __ ] e talking about right
and I'm and and what
sort of started describing it with is is
collecting Bitcoin and the the analogy
that I give to people is um is kind of
like imagine being alive 10,000 years
ago when we're still using shells and
rocks to trade you know or to measure
our value to measure our value you could
have found a yellow shiny rock on the
ground mhm and exchanged it with someone
for maybe a couple grains of salt or a
few spices because that person would
have looked at you and thought what the
hell am I gonna do with this yellow
shiny Rock I can't eat it I can't wear
it I can't drink it I can't do anything
with it
and you would have gone and traded that
entire chunk of gold for a bit of salt
because the rest of the world did not
know how to price it did not know how to
value it yeah we are at that point in
time with Bitcoin right now the rest of
the world has zero idea what money is
they have zero idea how to value this
new form of money they have zero idea
how to price it like what we're seeing
in the market is not bitcoins value what
we see in the marketplace is people's
perception of how to price a monetary
instrument that is unsensible
uncomfortable or inflatable and there is
very few people in the world that
understand how to price that so really
the game today is buying and closer
let's even get rid of the word buying
the the game today is collecting Bitcoin
in the same way as you could have
collected gold 5,000 years ago before
anybody else knew what it was worth yep
what and part of this too at least in my
opinion right this is purely my opinion
is if you look at gold and the
appreciation that it experiences how
1971 when we went off the gold standard
right since that day it has appreciated
over 40 X right
that's just price discovery and part of
that price discovery is what is gold
worth but some of that price discovery
is also the depreciation fail of the US
dollar right letter tens of that asset
and so bitcoin is gonna have both of
those occur
great this is gonna have the price
discovery plus the depreciation of
dollars and so what you get is one
Bitcoin he goes one Bitcoin just like
one ounce of gold is equal one ounce of
gold forever right but you're gonna get
the the movement is actually on the US
dollar side the US dollar is volatile
compared to Bitcoin it's not that
Bitcoin is volatile compared to u.s.
dollar a hundred percent and so you're
actually gonna get two effects with
Bitcoin you're gonna get that effect and
you're also gonna get the discovery
effect so you're gonna get the D
monetization of the US dollar effect but
I don't think that is gonna happen until
the later half of Bitcoin so that the
discovery element or the discovery
period is literally the period of the
world working out that we can have a
money that is non government-issued that
is superior to the money we have today
and once we've worked that out and it's
broadly enough help like once Bitcoin is
past a million dollars a coin at that
point you'll start to really see a
flight towards getting out of fiat
currencies and moving towards something
like that because I mean let's we
touched on labor before and and you know
I really want to just sort of mention
that like when labor came out I was like
this is so bullish for Bitcoin because
what it did it in in one fell swoop it
did two things number one it um it made
for the rest of the population of the
world it made the idea of a
non-sovereign issued money possible yep
when people like with Bitcoin people
like well how can you have a money
that's not it should go by the
government but now that Facebook is
should have people like maybe you can so
all of a sudden made the idea feasible
this was with a buddy of mine who uh who
I got to see if he's comfortable to me
saying that he's wooden said it but just
a friend of mine said to me there's a
lot of people who don't like Mark
Zuckerberg nobody thinks he's dumb right
so the fact that Mark Zuckerberg and
Facebook and all this stuff was
interested in a non-sovereign issued
currency all of a sudden legitimize that
idea yeah let me say this right now is
Facebook libras suck they're not
interested in blockchain they are
interested in money that is this is the
game people that there is no blockchain
here they're just using that as a
buzzword they're interested in money
because this is the separation of money
and state I'm going to everyone a blow
your mind even farther than that I mean
I see there
money what they JPMorgan HSBC Wells
Fargo all these people announcing
digital currencies they're not
interested just in money they're
interested in central banks and the
reason why is because today they're
saying I'm gonna issue a digital
currency it is backed by either a
commodity a currency or a basket of
currencies it's pegged to something
right that's where the value comes from
is my digital currency is backed by
something else but what I'm scared of in
the future is that they're going to
unpack it now they have a digital
currency they control it and they're
just a central bank they can print all
they want and so they become central
banks rather than just being in touch
with the money yeah well Crixus so what
I'm saying when I say money is I don't
mean they're interested in making money
like I'm saying they're interested in
money like yeah yeah actually that's
exactly what they're because that is the
game right now so I call it the
corporate central bank yeah well that's
it because like the way the world is
trending at the moment is you've got and
we sort of touched on this before arm we
started the podcast is you've got a
world that is increasingly moving
towards what might look like fed coin
which is the USD China coin which will
be a digital yuan you'll have
corporal Kean which is likely to be
Libre suck bucks and you'll have the one
bastion of freedom that is the money
that's owned by the people which will be
Bitcoin and people are gonna have an
opportunity to you know you know the
beauty of Bitcoin is that it's opt-in
and opt-out it doesn't care you can do
that any time you want
I wonder how difficult it's gonna be to
opt out of the other three I get the
feeling that it'll be easier to opt out
of something like a sock buck then it
will be to opt-out over you aren't right
yeah you know so but but this this is
literally gonna be the four different
you know factions of the world is you
know you'll probably have this whole
social credit system you know communism
under China you'll have hopefully
something a little bit freer in the u.s.
you'll have something that is more
fast-paced you know technologically sort
of driven and you know in in Facebook
but all inherently suffer from the same
problem which is this concentration of
who runs the money and the money is
actually owned by a small subset of the
cohort
within that jurisdiction whereas Bitcoin
is the one that is owned by the people
owned by everyone i watch one of our
investors through recently and i said
what you have to understand is just like
in investing doing something different
and being right is where all the
opportunities right and if you look at
every single monetary asset that we have
today and historically they have all had
one fundamental flaw which is they can
be debased curt and because they can be
debased that they can go on for very
long periods of time right they can
persist for decades centuries etc but
eventually they all fail because they
can be debased away bitcoin is the first
time that we have seen it globally
adopted money that is non-debatable
which ten hopefully drive not just a
short-term sustainability but can
actually drive a long-term
sustainability and should be able to
show and in some cases [ __ ] a lot of
the currencies that are debatable
because the flows will go to what has
the longest term sustainable track
record or outlook correct because and
this comes back to what we're saying
before the two phases right is we're in
the Bitcoin discovery phase right now so
during the Bitcoin discovery phase the
incentive to get into bitcoin is gains
you know and and as we're doing that
we're actually strengthening the Bitcoin
ecosystem we're strengthening its
security guarantee we're strengthening
its brand we're strengthening its market
capitalization we're increasing its
liquidity we're doing all that sorts
though at some point in time Bitcoin
will be the narrative will change in the
incentive to buy Bitcoin is no longer
gonna be the gains the incentive to buy
Bitcoin is going to be the aversion to
loss because at that point in time it's
gonna be I want to store my wealth in
something that is unsensible and unn
confiscated or a none inflatable sister
was so every single point in bitcoins
asymptotic life cycle you have an
incentive that is stronger than
everything else in the market yeah and
that's why it's unstoppable and it's
unbeatable like you're not gonna get an
and again we're not gonna replicate this
now that the liquidity train is off like
the the brand train is off the that
initial Immaculate Conception is done
like and you
this intolerant minority who will not
deviate like you don't have that
anywhere else in anything that I've ever
seen like I was saying this to Adam
Meister or saying if I come over who
else saying it - actually I was like
imagine if a brand today like an Apple
had a cohort of millions of people
running around doing podcasts flying
around the country doing all this sort
of stuff for something called Bitcoin
like what the hell like nobody has that
kind of brand like devotional fervency
so you point to corporations annual
expenses would be in the billions of
dollars in order to get the same impact
that this decentralized network with no
marketing budget has for sure it's
incredible and and people and this is
like when you look at all of that people
um when people tell me our Bitcoin is
not a good investment I was like man
that and this is why I believe like
today Bitcoin is the most contrary and
opportunity that exists today Bitcoin is
dismissed by the normal people
it's dismissed by the bankers it's
dismissed by the government it's
dismissed by blockchain errs it's
dismissed by crypto people
it's dismissed by all of these people
yet when you look at the first
principles it is the strongest thing
that exists today and as a result it is
the most contrary invest so the more
it's dismissed by some place it is
literally that is literally the
absolutely shout out Jason Williams had
just joined he's out here talking about
Danny dimes and Danny Bitcoin we're
gonna be done by 12:30 just so every
windows so we can go watch the New York
Giants win another football game all
right
getting back to of the important stuff
amber let's talk a little bit about what
you're building and how that fits into
this whole idea of collecting Bitcoin
well I have been talking to people for
the last three and a half years now to
just buy some Bitcoin and just just buy
some and shut up look literally that
that's sort of the UM the message and
you know three and a half years ago when
I first started talking to people it was
still difficult right you know like you
know maybe coinbase was sort of the app
that you could go to but um these days
it is a lot easier and effectively one
of my friends just said why don't you
stop talking about and you know build
something that makes it easier so I came
up with the idea of um of amber I was
like alright why don't we just round up
people spare change and invested into
Bitcoin so that's sort of where
initially started we've sort of moved
more towards that the dollar cost
averaging mean and you know move away
from spare change and more just help
people um accumulate Bitcoin by
downloading an app linking their bank
account setting an amount setting a
frequency and getting exposure to
Bitcoin in a manner that's sensible
because like I like to transcend the
idea of you know investing in Bitcoin is
great but most people are afraid of
investing or don't understand the
concept in investing so how about we
drive the meme of you know the variation
of stacking sets that I was mentioning
before which is collecting Bitcoin which
is today it's not it's not even about
investing in Bitcoin today it's
literally about collecting Bitcoin
you're collecting Bitcoin because the
rest of the world has not priced it yet
and by the time the rest of the world
prices it you're not going to be paying
ten grand for a Bitcoin you're going to
be paying millions for a Bitcoin and
there's not a chance in hell the average
person will be able to afford some I'm
writing a short story now which is that
the journey of a pre coiner and a
Bitcoin and I've got three characters in
there each who takes a different
approach to you know hearing Bitcoin
hearing about Bitcoin for the first time
one of them consistently thinks they've
missed the boat and they never get in
until Bitcoin is worth a million bucks
the second one thinks that they're
really smart and they try and buy and
they FOMO in at the top and they firma
out at the bottom and then the third one
is the guy who just takes a simple
approach of just slowly collecting and
he's the only student who has no money
but he just buys twenty bucks a week it
is I said this probably a year ago and
it was offhand comment didn't think too
much of it but somebody keeps repeating
it to me and now it's like ingrained in
my head is just Bitcoin is a game of
accumulation that's it right it is and
the reason why I like the words
collecting accumulating etc is when
you're collecting or accumulating
there's no that there's no
outflow yeah you're right and the idea
again is it changes the mindset of the
individual it changes the mindset of the
investor or the user from somebody who
is consumptive in their use of money
right versus somebody who is much more
into how do I say man you just touch
them such a good point like
this is one of the other armed zeitgeist
that Bitcoin represents in today's day
and age in a world where you know
supposedly GDP you know gross domestic
projects you know GDP is actually a
measure of consumption not production
like we're on the wrong side of the
equation here but in a world where
everything is optimized for consumption
for for you know for now Bitcoin
represents this one bastion where I'm
savings patients a low time preference
we're optimizing for a better future is
incentivized over spending consuming and
getting the next dopamine hit now and
it's such a it's such a profound thing
when you think about it because it's not
just the better money it's a better
lifestyle yeah absolutely
look I I talk about all the time one of
the best pieces of financial advice and
again this is an escaping financial
advice but just if you were to go ask
any financial advisor in the country
what is the number one thing that people
should do is quote pay yourself Yeah
right and pay yourself first and what
that means is make sure that you're
saving make sure that you're you're
putting money towards your goals and
then go pay your bills go do all these
things and the reason why that's
important is because if you quote pay
yourself first you don't even realize
that the money's gone
correct right correct so if you get a
thousand dollars in a paycheck and you
take $100 and you stick it in a savings
account every time you get your 900
bucks you don't even realize you're
saving $100 rich that pull dead 101
right it was literally pay yourself
first and what better way to pay
yourself then paying yourself in Bitcoin
because it is an artificially scarce
asset right and I continue to tell
people that it is more scarce than gold
is more scarce than land it is more
scarce than pretty much any asset you
can think of right because it has a
software-driven
artificial cap so there cannot be any
more of them that are created correct
well it's it's soft which it's all let's
say it's software enforced and it's
social consensus driven right yes so
like yeah we um we and this is again
comes back to the intolerant minority
all right is if this is a social
consensus driven thing we by definition
requires an intolerant minority who will
not deviate from the the core tenets of
what that social consensus is
and that forms the basis of you know the
core of Bitcoin and as Bitcoin continues
to stay around that core grows and the
Bitcoin consensus the base of it coin
consensus rules ossify and you then have
a like you know you mentioned before
money is this some you know belief
system and and it is like you know
fundamentally speaking like we're the
only species on the planet that you you
know have this tool which we decide to
call money in order to collaborate but
what's very very important is that you
can have a belief system that you know
there's an Bob Wian dollar is money the
problem is it's not based on any
objective attributes right outside of
trusting Mugabe or whoever the sky is to
run it right
whereas gold as an example had objective
attributes that we could collectively
come to consensus on what were a better
set of attributes to represent this
belief system of money Bitcoin has a far
superior set of attributes that through
this social consensus mechanism have
created a network that is now ossified
or or is to a large degree ossified
around being uncensored one confiscated
bull and fixed in supply right and with
those elements now we have a better form
of money we have something that is
superior and we have something that is
more liquid you know all of those sorts
of things that we mentioned before
and really just comes back to the point
about today the only game in town and
the most important game in town is buy
and accumulate Bitcoin collect Bitcoin
because at the end of the day this thing
like whether your as a fervent believer
as me or pomp you know and think that
you know this is the game like I'm I'm
buying Bitcoin now because I'm not gonna
trade it back for four dollars I'm not
looking for the gain I'm collecting it
because I want to participate in a
Bitcoin economic system in the future
and and that's what I'm basically
collecting for before everybody else
realizes what it's worth this is my edge
this is my that this is the edge that I
have on the rest of the world I book
it's what you believe that other people
haven't realized correct and so whether
you believe to that extent or whether
you don't believe to that extent
and you'll just think that our bitcoins
this interesting thing and you've seen
it grow from a dollar to you know ten
grand or whatever it is now that doesn't
matter where you are on the spectrum
having some exposure to Bitcoin now is
the smartest decision you can make yeah
but I think it's Parker and I apologize
it from Robert Parker Lewis he basically
says you know we're finally at a point
where it is more detrimental for you to
be wrong by not having exposure yep it
would be for you to have exposure view
yeah the risk is now greater exactly the
risk is now greater because there is a
higher probability now that this like
five years ago
I can understand right you know six
seven years ago I could understand it
was hard mount Cox this that like you
had a million on one things going wrong
I could understand right now there is
literally no excuse with apps like amber
with you know things like cash up that
there's things out there now which make
the exposure to Bitcoin in a sensible
manner simple and easy if you're not
holding Bitcoin right now look I'm sorry
you're deranged you've lost the plot
like it is it's borderline ignorance at
this point of time what talk through us
what exactly is the functionality of
amber and where can people go find out
or download yeah Amber's available in
Australia now next time you're not sure
you only in Australia right now next
step is gonna be UK and Europe we're
sort of working hard to get that rolled
out now the functionality is really
simple you download the app you link
your bank account you set an amount you
set a frequency you click done it's you
know within a minute you've um you've
bought your first bit of Bitcoin know
you can do recurring you can do a
one-off buy you can withdraw over to
your own wallet so we're really big
believers of you know your keys your
coins so we you know fundamentally built
the product to be an easy on-ramp if you
want to store some Bitcoin on amber by
all means go for 100% cold storage but
if you want to withdraw it out to your
own wallet by all means you can do that
as well we actually you know promote
that as a as a thing to do and that is
literally game set match for what
bitcoin tour for for what amber is today
down the track I what I sort of envision
is the reinvention of the financial
institution if we look at financial
institutions today they are the the
institution
that provide the function and access to
three things the ability to store send
and receive money in the future we've
moved the ability to store send and
receive down to the protocol level so
the financial institution of the future
is no longer gonna be the one that
facilitates and provides the function
they will only be the access point and
the best access point is gonna be the
best apps that provide the best features
for those people who want to participate
on a Bitcoin economic system and that's
sort of so when I look at what Amber's
future is gonna be I look at us being
what I like to call the Bitcoin bank
we're gonna reinvent what finance looks
like but do it all on top of Bitcoin
outside of the existing financial worlds
such that people can have the ability to
you know whether its lending borrowing
interest much facilities payments you
know access to other investment club
whatever it is you can do all of that on
Bitcoin 24/7 globally without borders
all on a Bitcoin denominated
infrastructure yeah and Bitcoin rails
and not on their legacy system and part
of this is if you can basically be the
portal or the entry point for people to
collect Bitcoin and acquire Bitcoin
accumulated whatever going to call it
you then can build on all the different
functionality around that correct
correct exactly you don't you don't
build out that other stuff before anyone
has Bitcoin so this is what I always
tell people because you see all these
apps these days like people around you
know building like pause terminals and
merchant facilities to accept Bitcoin
nobody's got Bitcoin like who the hell
is gonna pay you with Bitcoin we don't
have Bitcoin and furthermore when you
have Bitcoin and you buy a coffee for
five dollars and in five years time that
coffee actually cost you ten grand you
want to shoot yourself in the face so
it's the wrong thing so today the most
important thing to build is the product
that makes collecting Bitcoin as simple
as possible when you have a cohort of
people that have Bitcoin you can then
provide products and services that
enable them to utilize the Bitcoin in
other methods other than holding it
that's the best the most rational thing
I can think of for sure and it really
just comes down to again time preference
right literally well it's time
preference but it's also
self-preservation and looking after
yourself like most people will come into
Bitcoin initially they'll maybe trade it
for some [ __ ]
they might spend some Bitcoin you know
they'll do all that sort of stuff but
over time what they'll realize is that
they should have just held Bitcoin for
sure showing the shirt one more time so
he brought two things today got one
shirt there's one shirt but there's a
second shirt that he brought which is
Bitcoin not [ __ ] coin and then he also
brought me the Bitcoin times which is a
really really high quality magazine that
they can call it's a publication we keep
yeah it's gonna be we're gonna release
two a year so it's gonna be a limited
edition publication okay it's not about
news it's about long-form deep thought
content it's the the writers for so I
did the first one it was it was an
extension to a talk I gave and so I did
the first one the second one is going to
end subsequent ones are gonna be eight
riders per Edition by invitation only
who are gonna write long form deep well
thought out content for Bitcoin that is
going to be timeless so the idea is that
the stuff we write here is going to be
timeless and will stand the test of time
so people can come back and look on and
think holy crap what were these guys
thinking so a couple names I can mention
for the next edition which is gonna be
the last of this decade coming out in a
couple months is gonna be GG's gonna be
riding in their house McCook Nick cada
Murad and his brother Mercier we've got
a couple awesome riders like that so
there's a couple more Dan hell's gonna
be writing a piece in it and effectively
we just want to have timeless content in
there and what we will also do each
Edition we're going to print 2100 of
them
satoshi baby we're gonna print 2100 of
them and have them up for sale on a on a
lightning denominated on B TCP server
shot and so people can go to
it says Bitcoin x dot news here is is
where some of those will be and then
there will be a bunch of them y'all I'm
sure you'll see it all over Twitter etc
and because most of you guys know that I
will I'll tell you what people put
inside the books this is number four of
five and it says Bitcoin not [ __ ] coin
let's change the world pop which all of
you at home know is is exactly what
we're trying to do here so it's it's
awesome thank you very much for this
dude really appreciate understand and by
the way in case you're unintelligent it
says the end at the end so that you know
that it's over
uh-huh all right before I wrap up I
always do a rapid-fire set of questions
do you think is the most important
company in Bitcoin today ooh I'm biased
because I think it's made bit so
normally I say not including your own
company and I didn't think you were
going to say that but go ahead so nine
thirty year old company okay um I really
really like the stuff that um I would
have said back in the day zapper but I
really like what Unchained capital is
doing and then there's probably on what
Rodolfo is doing with cold card and
stuff so but but in different elements
so somewhere in that sort of space is
self custody and more intelligent you
know non self custody okay
what's the one regulation you would
change or improve if you could
regulation um if I was a government and
I had a brain I would um I would be
buying Bitcoin and I would make it I
would make it easier for everyone to buy
a Bitcoin because they gain anything it
touches that exactly so so if you can
make it easier for people within your
jurisdiction to buy Bitcoin you're gonna
have wealthier people smarter people
come to jurisdiction simple as that what
is the most controversial thought you
have in Bitcoin I mean the I mean
Bitcoin not [ __ ] Quinn has you know it's
no longer controversial I would say I
would say toxicity is really really
important I would say it's the white
blood cell mechanism inside Bitcoin is
um you know white blood cells are toxic
to disease and I would say us Bitcoin is
that intolerant minority are the white
blood cells in Bitcoin and we must stay
strong and irrespective of what people
call us whether it's toxic whether is
whatever [ __ ] name they want to give
us we must maintain that standard
because it you know if we don't no one
else will I love it what's the most
important book you've ever read
um I'm rent um
Atlas Shrugged yeah it used to be it
used to be skin in the game by Tyler but
uh mine Rand's Atlas Shrugged like she
literally predicted Bitcoin seven years
ago it's pretty crazy
did ya aliens believer non-believer who
ever met one before probabilistically it
makes sense
uh hmm
I think definitely if okay I'll put this
cave yet if there are they're not in a
galaxy anywhere near us okay but but
probabilistically they exist just a
different galaxy yeah yeah alright do
you think that we would be able to reach
them in our lifetime no no chance no
what if they come here they ain't come
Neil no yeah why not too far away if
it's if it's if like that yeah I think
if they're in a galaxy it'll be a galaxy
very far far away and I don't think
we're on we're catching up anytime soon
not in this lifetime at least you know
and you know maybe maybe you know five
ten generations from now all right
that's fair seven minutes left before I
have to go watch the New York Giants
march towards another Super Bowl
championship for all you clowns at home
who disagree leave me alone uh huh what
one question do you have for me to
finish this up hmm we asked in the
audience I'm asking ya you ask me I'm
sure they'll chime in okay okay okay
okay all right um how rough can I be
with these questions as rough as you
want you can people have asked me all
kinds of crazy stuff okay okay um see I
personally don't see any value in all of
this blockchain er II [ __ ] that's going
on and around Bitcoin so what what is it
that intrigues you and why do you sort
of drive narratives around you know
blockchain being something special or um
you know all that stuff so the short
answer is automation right and I look at
a whole bunch of aspects of the world
that are going to end up being automated
we use the word blockchain we talked a
little bit about this before start
recording because there are elements of
what a blockchain looks like that are
being incorporated etc I would say 99%
of the things that are being called
block shins or not actually block chains
right there they're some variation or
they've got components of it etc but for
us and we've started to really I think
change the way that we talk about some
of the stuff because it's not about
critical blockchain technology is truly
about automation right yeah and so we
start to say things like you know if
people were all upset in in the etherium
community because I recently came out
and said it's not about defy it's about
automated finance right and so it's like
you know some of the automated finance
products will be decentralized but not
or I'm sorry some of them will but not
all of them but 100% of the
decentralized financial products will be
automated yes right and so the
automation is actually the bigger trend
than the decentralization and so when
you look at it that way it's like are
there certain things that will be
decentralized whether it's you know defy
or other aspects that people are trying
to incorporate quickl blockchain it -
yeah sure like I'll buy that there will
be some people who build decentralized
things they get value you could argue
Wikipedia for example is quote unquote
decentralized in some degree right
doesn't involve blockchain all rights
correct but in those level of attention
yeah exactly and so for us it's you know
the things that become interesting or
when you have the automation as the
endgame read or or is what they're
building and so the best companies that
we've invested in who are not Bitcoin
related or interface with Bitcoin resume
they have some kind of application of
elements of a blockchain outside of
Bitcoin when they pitch us don't even
talk about watching right and the only
time that we uncover that there's
elements of the blockchain is when we do
the technical diligence and you look
into the technology stack and it's like
oh that looks like I'm watching ok right
I mean well ok what do you mean by looks
like a blockchain what what is so
everyone look like yeah so I'll give it
I'll give a direct example so as most
people know largest investment we've
made in our fund is company called
figure technologies what figures doing
is they're basically digitizing and
automating at first it's mortgage
origination but really they're replacing
DTCC right now DTCC to build that fully
decentralized dtc
Siana blockchain and anyone can validate
any transaction etc would be I would
argue nearly impossible if not
impossible right to replace that legacy
piece of infrastructure so what these
guys have done is they've taken
something that has a lot of components
of what are like a Bitcoin blockchain
would have and they've said we're going
to get large institutions to validate
the transactions okay looks like a Libra
type Association mm-hmm but it's not
it's not a true blockchain in the sense
of a fully decentralized inmutable etc
you're dealing with financial assets
that you know if I have a stock
certificate that's a bearer asset and
you hack me well the corporation is not
comfortable with you now having a hacked
stock certificate that you hold right so
you have to have certain elements that
Bitcoin actually our core strengths
can't be core strengths in these other
assets and so for us like that system
the value proposition of figure is
there's a quote-unquote digital mortgage
but the true value proposition why that
is the automations you go within five
minutes they tell you whether you're
gonna get it or not they fund it within
four days yeah right that user
experience is compared to a 45-day HELOC
origination process and legacy world yes
yes so I think blockchain is just the
word that gets thrown around agree to
cover up you know the reality so I
remember when the smart contracts became
a big name and I was just saying smart
contracts nothing special it's just
business process automation it's like
literally writing code like if this then
that function yeah that is what code has
existed for since the beginning of time
you know it's not a smart contract this
is just code that that's literally it
and we choke we're like nobody comes
nobody comes to our office and pictures
us and says have a MongoDB cup that's it
right or I have an excel file company
and so when people come in to have a
blockchain company the way that we think
about it and this is evolved over time
right but but the way that we think
about it today I think is that's just
one of the technologies that you use
your technology stack but it's much more
focused on the automation and that's
where the value proposition comes from
it's not that you're just using a
certain piece of technology yeah I mean
I would take the argument just one step
further and I would just say that people
should remove that [ __ ] the word
blockchain from any of the or any their
vernacular because it just it's not what
it is like if we're gonna describe
Bitcoin as a you know as a blockchain
which I think is almost in
to Bitcoin because like here's a fun
fact then I don't know if you know this
but the word blockchain was never used
in the Bitcoin white paper you know that
right
I did not know that yeah that's good
he's not as pretty because that the word
blockchain came out in 2011 I love that
yes so that so it never existed so the
correct definition of Bitcoin is
actually a time chain like Bitcoin
actually is something that it is
designed so that you can't go back in
time because traditionally like in the
real world the one thing that we can't
do is we can't reverse time every action
goes forward bitcoin is a digital
version of that it's the only digital
network that can only go forward in time
you cannot reverse anything or it's
probabilistically you know difficult to
reverse something and that was the
innovation that Bitcoin gave us is
digital immutability and scarcity and
that entire recipe that Bitcoin
represents decentralization you know
segregated time stamps you know data
chunks blockchain you know incentive
disincentive mechanisms economics game
theory all this sort of stuff has been
mish mash together to deliver digital
immutability and scarcity there's no
point in taking elements you know sub
components and I'll write about this in
Bitcoin times I say if you take one
element out of it ie the data structure
and you try and sell it as immutable or
wherever you're lying
because that's not what you're selling
you're literally just taking a timestamp
database which we've had for twenty
thirty years it doesn't matter so well
it's like and so figure for example they
called their you know their settlement
system provenance because it's more
about who owns it at given time rather
than them you right and that's not a
blockchain yep and that's fantastic and
I think that's a great product and I've
been going around saying this to people
for ages is you don't need a [ __ ] coin
you don't need a blockchain you just
need good tech that automates things
that makes things faster that makes
things better and there has a better
user experience and that is where the
innovation is going to be and when we
look at you know again another network
effects for Bitcoin and I'll end on this
is that what your as Bitcoin becomes
this stable settlement layer we're going
to be able to build products and
services driven around automation that
can query and access and take the
guarantee that Bitcoin provides and
abstract that out to deliver financial
services that we've never been able to
do
in the traditional world because you
cannot get instant settlement finality
and a guarantee of that through a
traditional central bank bitcoin is the
central bank of the internet like that's
what it is
Bitcoin not [ __ ] coins Bitcoin not [ __ ]
okay alright man listen I appreciate it
very much thank you for so much for
coming to do this
I appreciate the gifts and I want to do
it again in the future 100% brother
thank you hey everyone
pop here if you like this episode of off
the chain and want to help us take
crypto to the top of the Apple Spotify
and other podcast charts please do us a
favor and rate review and subscribe to
review simply go to the off-the-chain
homepage scroll down until you see the
five blank stars taking 15 seconds to
fill those stars in and leave a quick
review goes a long way and helping us
take the entire crypto ecosystem to the
top of the charts I appreciate you
listening and see you next time on off
the chain